right
let's get back to it so thank you hamsa
for taking up the mantle of the last
Talk of the day but the good thing is
she's an amazing speaker so we'll be
fine
um so yeah so I'm pleasure to introduce
and she's uh she had bought in school
University of Pennsylvania and uh it's
great uh to have you here again and uh
she'll talk about learning across
Vandals
thank you Shipra oh this is on okay
foreign
for the last session and apologies uh
for making you stick around to the last
session I'll try to keep it snappy uh
this is work primarily by my PhD student
konshu uh who is on the job market uh
and so I'm really gonna be borrowing
heavily from his work uh on learning
across Bandits and high dimension uh via
robust statistics
um so I always like to start off with a
little motivation about why we should
care about these problems in practice so
I think generally if you work in kind of
resource constraint settings we often
face uh practical small data challenges
there are several reasons you might have
a new predictive task like a new drug or
a new disease like covid-19 you might
have imbalance or rare outcomes so that
the outcomes that you're looking to
measure might have very very high
variance because of that you might have
non-stationarity I think this is always
true in practice but if it's excessive
then
um you start having a very limited
window of training data that's
representative and finally you often
have high dimensional features and so
that means that that doesn't necessarily
increase variance but it means we need
more data to do effective inference
which makes problems hard when we're
faced with these kind of small data
challenges right uh and so two popular
approaches for dealing with this kind of
small data problem one is to do Bandits
so adaptability we collect data in
regions where our model is most
uncertain so that we try to be efficient
with the limited budget that we have and
another thing is to do transfer learning
try to leverage auxiliary data streams
uh to reduce variants of the current
estimator that we have right uh and
these two literatures are largely
independent although there is a growing
stream of literature kind of at the
intersection and I think they actually
go really well together because uh often
when you try to deploy bandits in kind
of small data settings the Bandit always
ends up always exploring because there
are variants of every arm is kind of
prohibitively large and so it doesn't
actually get to exploit within a small
time Horizon T and so transfer learning
can kind of be critical to reduce the
variance so that we actually move from
exploration to exploitation uh so I'm
going to give an example based on some
work with chemo and so he's going to
talk about this as a teaser I mean
consider this a teaser uh next week in
two weeks
okay very soon in the next workshop and
you'll do a much better job than me so
you should definitely attend that talk
uh but we did some work with Vishal
Gupta on targeted covid-19 testing uh
basically we were looking at tourist
arrivals to Greece in the summer of 2020
we had a very limited budget of tests to
allocate to these arrivals so only about
six to eight thousand people could be
tested and the goal was to identify as
many infected Travelers as possible
so this is a pretty standard kind of
Band-Aid problem you have people coming
in with some features that we used to
predict how risky they are for covid and
then based on that we decide whether or
not to allocate a test to them given a
limited budget we get feedback back from
those tests that those feedback into our
system to build new predictive models
and then we kind of continue this
feedback loop uh so the objective is
basically I'm not going to go into any
details to maximize the number of
expected infections caught and we have a
standard exploration exploitation
trade-off in the sense that we want to
test enough passengers of different
types so that we know whether or not
they're risky and then uh on the other
hand we also want to use these estimates
to basically figure out who is the most
risky so we can you know find and
quarantine them right so standard
Solutions you can use upper confidence
Doms and sampling whatever you want uh
so keymon will probably talk about how
there are a lot of other practical
challenges that we also addressed uh but
I'm not really interested in that for
this talk I just want to kind of focus
on the small data challenge right so we
had very very imbalanced data here so if
you test about 500 people only one of
them will test positive which is
excellent from a public health
perspective if a lot more people than
that were testing positive you have a
real problem and you shouldn't be
opening your borders but this also means
that even if you test thousands of
people a day you're really only getting
a handful of positives and so you have
huge variants and on top of that uh the
main feature we're using origin location
is kind of a very high dimensional
categorical variable with many many
levels right so this means that if you
actually try to look at the variance of
your estimator of risk for any kind of
subpopulation it's huge
um so Michelle made this cute plot where
like uh on the x-axis we basically have
this empirical base like prior strength
uh the challenge here is that predicting
just zero for everyone's risk is already
a very very good estimator right because
one in 500 people test positive so if I
just said no one is positive I would get
99.5 accuracy yeah we win we call it a
day right but of course it's just
prescriptively useless
um and so our goal is to do better than
that if you use a classical estimate
that doesn't kind of do any transfer
learning you can't really beat this or
at least we weren't able to beat it and
so we use the heuristic that basically
use lasso for Dimension reduction from
that original High dimensional feature
space and then empirical base to kind of
do some knowledge sharing across types
uh and so this actually was better than
the zero estimator I won't talk any more
about this example but uh it was
effective we caught more cases than
random testing right uh but this really
brought us to this question which is you
know how do we learn in a principled way
not some sort of heuristic across many
simultaneous heterogeneous contextual
bandits in moderate to high dimension
right uh which is really the focus of
this talking what uh Khan has been
working on
so there is a lot of Prior work on kind
of studying multitask Bandits uh they
usually use like you need to relate the
parameters in some way they kind of use
Ridge regularization or a shared
Bayesian prior or something like that
unfortunately none of these really uh
improve and sometimes they actually
worsen their regret bounds uh and I
think this is sort of unescapable
um unless you want to impose some sort
of structural assumption so what we do
here is basically we look at a bunch of
real data sets and we try to impose what
we think is kind of a reasonable uh
structural assumption which we think uh
which we can provably show improves
performance uh and we want to pay
special attention to these data poor
instances so locations or arms that have
very little sample points uh because
those are the ones that kind of hold up
the Bandit in its path
and please interrupt me if you have any
questions thoughts
so this is a pretty General problem it's
not you know it does for covet testing
or something like that so if you were
thinking about you know do Dynamic
pricing or Inventory management you can
think of each Bandit as like a different
store every store is different it faces
a different customer population
different Trends and so on and so you
want to kind of personalize it to that
location on the other hand you want to
do some knowledge sharing so that you
actually converge faster uh similarly
imagine that you have a a network of
hospitals or health facilities uh you
can treat each of those facilities as a
separate Bandit instance but at the same
time you want to do some knowledge
sharing across locations because
ultimately these are all kind of small
data problems
okay so let me jump into formulating
this so this is a single contextual
Bandit so imagine that you have
basically uh one hospital or service
provider you have a bunch of arms you
have K arms each with some parameter
vector and so we observe you know uh at
each time step uh an individual arrived
with some feature Vector X1 X2 X3 and so
on uh we're just going to consider a
linear contextual Bandit so uh if you
choose an arm K with unknown parameter
beta K we observe reward you know just X
transpose uh beta K plus some sub
gaussian noise so the very very standard
framework
um and we all know how to solve this
there's been tons of work done on this
you know kind of pull up any of these
algorithms if I didn't say you I
apologize I ran out of space
um you know you can imagine now taking a
better perspective right let's say I
have many different Bandit algorithms
operating at the same time now I have n
different instances uh contexts are
people are going to arrive at each of
these service providers with some
probability Pi so these P's will sum to
one uh and each instance has its own set
of unknown arm parameters so note that
these are now different so the same uh
treatment or intervention at a different
location might actually have kind of a
different parameter Vector due to the
idiosyncratic biases that are associated
with a specific provider so I'll show
you a numerical example in a little bit
um and so now we have individuals
arriving so with probability P1 uh they
come to our uh the first provider then
we're probably P3 maybe they come to the
third provider uh and so on and so forth
uh and you'll see that depending on what
these values of PR some locations might
be data poor because it's very unlikely
that they actually get uh customers
because um maybe they're small or they
serve a rural location
um other locations might get a
relatively proportionally large number
of individuals
okay so this is an uh regressions that
uh Khan ran on uh diabetes diagnosis
data so this is actually clean Theta
across 13 different hospitals uh where
he was trying to predict diabetes
diagnosis on the next visit so a fairly
standard kind of prediction task uh and
so what we're looking at is the Adaptive
error rate over time as we look at the
number of patients note that the Horizon
length is pretty small in healthcare
it's not like you can look at thousands
of patients you know like 175 is
actually fairly large uh and this gray
line here is the Oracle so the first
thing you'll see is that the green line
if you were to just ignore all of the
other hospitals and do one Bandit per uh
Hospital which is a single Bandit you
get a lot of variants So eventually this
is going to converge to a No Regret
policy but
um there's a lot of variance because you
have very little information to work
with right
um if you do data pooling so I just kind
of treat all of the hospitals data
points as the same game
um you actually get this blue line over
here which originally in the in the
short time Horizon does much better
because I have more samples but then as
I continue it actually kind of flattens
out uh and that's because this is a bias
estimator right like I'm not
um treating this Hospital's
idiosyncratic biases differently from
the other 12 hospitals and you'll see
the hospital data sets especially models
don't transport well uh and so this is
important to incorporate uh and so this
actually ends up not doing much better
than the single Bandit and the algorithm
we'll talk about the red line over here
kind of tries to gracefully interpolate
between these two extremes
yeah so just make sure so your reward
here was like did you get the prediction
for
like the regret uh but this is just for
illustration yeah
absolutely
um
yeah then you have the number of
different magnets right so what is
foreign
but you know
and it's the number of consensus uh the
number of arms uh our dependence is kind
of the same as in the regular contextual
bandages we're not doing sharing across
arms you could do that uh over things
you might sharing for the same arm
across instances so we don't really
change that as the number of instances
grows yeah
put the blue and red become closer so
the blue is hopelessly biased uh because
it's treating data this is a very simple
naive Baseline it pulls all the data
from all instances uh and so if I'm I'm
basically bringing in data from a
predictive model that's not the correct
predictive model so it's never going to
converge to the oracle
uh whereas the red is going to you know
discard data from
um from these proxies
the green will eventually meet the
Oracle yeah exactly yeah
everything
yeah this might become clearer when I
say um the assumption that we're gonna
make uh so in general you might say Okay
beta 1 beta 2 Beta 3 are like totally
different right for each hospital I mean
that is kind of what the multitask
banded literature has done like maybe
they're small but like as we take T to
be large it doesn't it really it's a
constant right
um and so what we're going to impose
instead uh is a slightly stronger
assumption which is that each arm
parameter can be decomposed into the sum
of a shared Global parameter so note
that these vectors are all different
they're colored differently uh but then
this there I'm gonna write it as a sum
of the same Vector plus a sparse instant
specific Vector right so white squares
here means that that component is zero
uh and so basically we're saying like
Okay we're talking about a diabetes
treatment or something like that there
is a specific shared uh predictive
Vector that's true for all locations but
then each location has some sort of bias
which is going trying to corrupt that
predictive model that's why models don't
transport well but that model is somehow
of lower complexity so we can project it
down into a a lower dimensional learning
problem so we're going to say that this
Delta here is sparse with l0 Norm s
where s is much smaller than d
so that's really what we're going to
leverage so you might say why are you
making this assumption uh well okay so
if we look at the diabetes Hospital data
this is what it looks like let me break
this down a bit so this is after we've
removed what we've estimated to be the
global shared parameter so on the x-axis
we have all 75-ish features on the
y-axis we have all 13 hospitals
um and so basically a single row of this
of this Matrix is going to be the Delta
the idiosyncratic bias term
corresponding to that specific hospital
so this is it for Hospital seven and a
colored Square indicates that there's a
statistically significant non-zero value
at that point so what we're seeing here
is basically every hospital does have
some sort of bias and those biases are
totally different they're completely uh
not aligned right uh and so we actually
dug into some of these so for some of
them there might be something like uh
you know and the reason they're
happening is because there are patient
population differences or biases and
measurements such as area has done a
bunch of work on this
um so for example you might look at
impaired fasting glucose which is ICD-9
code 79 790.21 this is actually super
predictive of having diabetes because if
you have impaired fasting glucose you
basically have pre-diabetes but
unfortunately it doesn't get recorded
for most patients and it actually varies
by Hospital how often it gets recorded
because it actually requires the patient
fast right and so depending on how you
know on top of things your provider is
uh and how you know conscious that
patient population is this feature may
or may not be censored and if it's not
censored then it's very predictive if it
is censored it isn't predictive right so
that means that if I train my model in a
hospital where people are consistently
measuring this feature and then I use it
on a hospital where they're not
consistently measuring that feature it's
not going to work well right these are
the biases we're trying to capture
that's easy to capture in a sparse
vector because I just need you know the
few features that are correlated with
that particular feature
similarly there's other issues like if
we look at BMI data the hospital the BMI
distribution across hospitals is kind of
similar but some hospitals actually
record an obesity diagnosis for the uh
the tail of distribution of those
patients uh but that's not true
everywhere of course obesity when
present is predictive of diabetes uh but
then you can't transport that model to a
hospital that doesn't record it right
so we have a plus Vector
um and then it's just saying that this
is the sparse Matrix so most entries are
zero
um and I'm also going to empirically
note the fact that there are no like
columns there are not many columns that
are all zero
um so these the non-zero entries are
kind of randomly spread out which makes
the problem harder
foreign
let me just briefly bring this back to
the related literature so there's been a
lot of work on multitask transfer meta
learning uh but again uh without
imposing this sort of an assumption or
some structure it's hard to basically
improve performance bound so that's
really what we're leveraging here
um and so we introduce a new multitask
estimator it turns out this structure is
non-trivial to leverage so we combine
kind of robust statistics and laws so to
do this which as far as I know is a
pretty uh novel combination for an
estimator uh and then we embed this into
a multitask Bandit algorithm to show
that we can actually get uh regret bound
improvements uh which again
um I think are not present in literature
so first I'm going to just talk about
the supervised learning problem uh and
then we'll stick this into a bandit
right okay so let's say I have data
across n neighboring instances and each
one has some sparsity level s for my
idiosyncratic parameter so what does my
data look like uh each instance has NJ
observations so XJ is my feature Matrix
YJ is my response column
um and so I and based on my assumption I
can write beta J as a global parameter
plus the instant specific bias uh and
then plus noise and my goal is to
estimate each beta J right
uh and so I'm going to consider two
cases the standard case the standard
case is when uh my hospital has a
similar data size as other hospitals so
I'm you know kind of an average Hospital
uh and the data poor case this is
especially the one we're interested in
where I'm like in a rural hospital or
something like that that gets very few
observations and so maybe you know my
sample size is way smaller and I really
need to transfer them right
um okay so we'll start with uh to build
some intuition using some simple
baselines the dumbest thing you could do
is to just do the single uh OLS
estimator right I'm not going to do any
transfer learning I'm just going to fit
I know it's a linear model I'm going to
fit an OLS estimator uh this is unbiased
but of course it's going to have high
variance when my sample size NJ is small
uh and so what am I gonna get
um so in the standard regime or the data
Port regime I get something like d over
root and J I'm looking at L1 error and
this is actually a lower bound
well-known
uh so you might say okay that's silly
like uh obviously I have uh data from
all these other hospitals I want to kind
of bring that in right to do better so
one thing you could do which some of my
colleagues are important stats did is to
kind of average like this comes from
Federated learning maybe I average all
my linear regression parameters across
all the locations right that's one thing
you could do another thing you could do
is to pull my data together that's kind
of the red line that I showed you before
so I treat all the data from all my
hospitals equally uh and then I just fit
a single linear regression right and
then you get this estimator uh it turns
out both of these actually have the same
lower bound uh and they're low variants
now I have a lot more data but High bias
so particularly in the standard regime
I'm gonna get a big Improvement on my
variance so instead of D over root and J
I get D over root begin NJ which is tiny
but then I get this Delta jl1 Norm bias
so that comes from the fact that I'm not
accounting for this hospital-specific
idiosyncratic behaviors so like that you
know obesity encoding or something like
that uh in the data for regime my
variance is even lower right because I
know that my sample size is much smaller
than my neighbor's sample size is but
I'm still not getting rid of this bias
which is kind of really the bottleneck
at this point right
uh so you might say okay let's try to
de-bias uh the shared model estimate
right so I'll also try to estimate Delta
J so what might you do in the first step
maybe I average together my
um my linear regressions to get an
estimate of that shared parameter that
Global parameter uh and in the Second
Step I'm basically going to run a lasso
on uh instance J's data to try to
estimate Delta J which is as far as
parameters so you know hopefully the
sample complexity isn't too bad but
foreign the problem is that step one
does not converge to the shared
parameter it converges to the shared
parameter plus the average of the biases
across all n locations right yes
uh you don't need to know s for this
estimator but the bond the bounds depend
on us
ually you just pick the Lambda by your
cross validation
that's what we did in the plots
other questions
um okay so let's see what happens here
um so if so again this is a similar plot
as before except uh now I've transposed
it uh so every column is a Delta
corresponding to each instance so I have
six instances here and uh the the uh the
the rows are basically like the feature
components right uh and so in the nice
case where all my uh Corruptions or
non-zero values kind of aligned in the
same rows so along the same features
this is actually fine because then the
average of my bias is also kind of
sparse uh and so I can actually just use
lasso to de-bias this in the Second Step
so nothing bad happens but I'll remind
you that when we looked at real data
this was not the case the by the
non-zero terms were kind of spread out
all over the board and so the real more
realistic picture looks more like this
where like you know the blue squares the
non-zero components are kind of like all
over the place and they're not well
aligned and if that's the case then the
average of the bias terms is also not
going to be sparse which means that you
can't use lasso in step two to debias
this so if we actually compute the lower
bound we actually see that we've made no
progress
um so like this variance is basically
the same this bias is actually uh
possibly larger when n is large NS is
going to be much larger than D and so we
haven't actually made any progress over
just the independent OLS estimator
uh so those are sort of the simple
things that we started out trying
but this actually gives us like a pretty
good idea so I'm going to introduce what
we call the robust multitask estimator
where we're actually going to split up
our components like our D different
feature components into two subsets uh
one subset we're going to call the
poorly aligned component so that means
that in any given row we only have a few
of these non-zero blue squares uh so
obviously we're not going to know odd
priori what this is going to be I'm just
going to argue that we don't actually
need to know it so this means that fewer
than Zeta n of the instances have
support along these components and in
the remaining I'm going to call the dark
blue squares the well-aligned component
so that means that maybe more than Zeta
n or the majority of these components
actually have support right uh and by
pigeonhole principle we know that we
can't have too many well-aligned
components in fact we can't have more
than S over Zeta of them the reason
being I know that each of these columns
is s bars so the SN plus srsd possible
entries in here uh sorry NS possible
entries in here uh and if I want
basically a lot of things where I have
more than Zeta and terms in a single row
I can have at most s of those components
right
that's going to be like the kind of the
key argument right so there are not too
many of these like bad components
so in the first step before we used an
average instead of that we're going to
use a robust statistic so we're just
going to use the trimmed mean uh you
could use the median but it doesn't have
as nice properties
um or it's less General and so what does
a trim mean do uh basically it'll
converge to what our Global parameter
component is going to be for those
poorly aligned components so let's say
that we have we take this particular
component D which has very few non-zero
entries uh let's say it's three zero
zero minus four zero zero uh the trim
mean will basically order these and then
once we order these it trims off the
tails uh so we scratch off Zeta and
values on both ends and then we take the
average of what's left right and that
average is zero even though this average
was not actually zero right so basically
just kind of removes these Corruptions
treating them these non-zero values
treating them as outliers uh so that's
great
um and then we're just left with the
well-aligned components well we know
that the well-line components there's
only as far as number of them by a
pigeonhole principle and so we can just
include that as part of our lasso
regression to actually debias those as
well right uh so we're done so basically
this breaks up into a sum of three
quantities so beta J minus beta hat rm0
so that's my robust estimate of the
global shared parameter is going to be
beta J minus beta0 which is a sparse
term I can d by a set of my second step
beta0 I'll get back to that the second
the third term which is just uh you know
uh noise so it's not sparse but it's
small it satisfies you know standard
tail inequalities and then we've shown
by original principle that this guy is s
over Z as far as and so this whole thing
is sparse or approximately sparse uh and
so all we're doing is that we're using
we're taking this robust statistics to
estimate the shared components and then
after that we're going to de-bias it for
forward to learn my instant specific
model using lasso so it's a two-step
estimator
that's a very nice question so is there
a reason that we cannot do uh lasso
together for multiple tasks
[Music]
so uh we're not we're all for us like
our parameters are all dense so they're
not group spars or anything like that is
that what you're asking so I was saying
is I basically do the previous version
but instead of breaking down two steps
apps yeah I just put yourself one
problem where I'm learning this share
beta and Delta and Delta is supposed to
be have like this processed small hour
known before you're doing this right and
for multiple tasks together so you can
do this for averaging multitask you're
absolutely right although we don't know
how to get a lower ground for that uh
but you could do it in one step but the
second one you can't because we're in
the after we are estimator in the center
in the first step we're now going to do
this component by component robust
trimmed mean right so that argument
breaks if you try to do it together it's
not just a regression problem it's also
sort of an outlier of a little problem
but if I do it in one step I will get
this I based on it
task I just added together right but
that actually doesn't converge so the
way we've stated our model is kind of
weird right like beta0 isn't like
identifiable right there's actually a
big l0 ball of potential estimate uh
from what we can tell we couldn't
actually get something that was in that
l0 revolve without doing something like
this
like this but I'm not arguing that there
isn't
it
other
yeah
um okay so if we actually plug this in
to get upper but we can now get upper
bounds we want to compare our upper
bounds to the lower bounds of baselines
so if we can say that the upper bound of
what we've done is kind of lower than
the lower bounds of the naive bass lines
and we've actually made progress right
um so that's all we're trying to do here
uh so in the standard regime we
basically see that we shave off a factor
of square root D and we replace it with
square root S so that's nice
um and then we still keep the low
variance associated with the averaging
estimator so we basically have this
variance term uh from over here we've
removed the bias completely but then we
pay this extra cost uh but I think it's
more interesting in the data poor regime
where we actually shave off the the the
dimension dependence completely so I've
hidden log factors here uh but you can
see that it only depends on S over root
and J it's actually really intuitive to
imagine why this happens I'm basically
using all of the other hospitals to
learn my global shared parameter once I
know my Global shared parameter you know
is just a sparse learning problem right
but it's nice to see that it kind of
recovers that limit right
great so now we've all only talked about
supervised learning I'm going to go back
and stick this into a multitask Bandit
algorithm
um you can essentially embed this into
any linear contextual bandage but
because there's a lasso in there it's a
little hard to analyze without embedding
it into a high dimensional contextual
Bandit so that's what we did
um so we're basically building on prior
work here but there's two innovations
that we had to make uh one is that uh
the multitask estimator actually
introduces annoying correlations that
you don't have in a single banded
instance because now you're learning uh
across locations so that Global shared
parameter is sort of endogenous and so
we introduce a batching strategy to
basically kill those correlations and
the second thing is that how we Trim in
that trimmed mean also has to be uh
tuned to math to deal with a bias
variance trade-off so in particular like
when we have very few patients the
single banded so green here is variance
red is biased is the single Bandit
actually has a lot of variants and the
robust bandit has like you know some
bias and some variance if we don't tune
that bias variant straight off
eventually the single branded is
actually going to take over right
because its variance keeps dropping our
variance keeps dropping too but our bias
kind of never goes away right uh and so
what we actually need to do is make sure
that we aggressively trim so that uh
that trimming parameters data that I
showed you has to keep on increasing
with your time Horizon so that you can
actually
um match how the bias dies off with how
the variance dies off okay
um and so if we plug this in we get some
regret balance so and the first row is a
single banded regret bonds from the
literature uh and in the second row is
kind of a robust multitask Bandit bounds
uh that we get uh and again broken down
by standard instance or data for
instance so in the standard instance you
again you see that um we shave off a
factor of D and we replace it with X it
is worse by a factor of log T and I
think this is just because the high
dimensional banded algorithm is worse by
a factor of log t uh I don't think
that's actually supposed to be there but
we don't know how to get rid of it
um but what's really interesting is the
data core instance right so again now we
get this exponential Improvement in d uh
we used to have a D Squared now we have
an S squared right so again highlighting
that you know transfer learning is kind
of most important for instances where we
have very few samples that's why we
needed it for covet testing because most
countries where data poor countries
um and so this was sort of necessary
right
foreign
so I'll make a few remarks so I think a
couple things that we tried to do when
designing this algorithm or other
contrary to do in designing this
algorithm one is that it's a Federated
approach uh so you don't actually need
to share raw training data we only share
the aggregate regression parameters when
we take the robust mean uh and so that's
nice because uh hospitals usually don't
like to share uh raw EHR data uh second
of all it's also fair in the sense that
uh we're trying to we get the larger
improvements for data for instances
which we think is useful because a lot
of hospitals that are kind of data poor
tend to be rural hospitals or
one-serving minorities they're also the
ones that suffer from more of these
idiosyncratic biases because they don't
follow up with patients as much uh and
so I think there's something interesting
to be said about how transfer learning
could reduce kind of the price of
fairness literature that's kind of been
studied in Ops
um and then finally this is really easy
from a production constraint standpoint
because uh you know we're doing it in a
batched way and so you only need a few
batched offline updates to your models
uh this is not you know like something
that's going to adaptively run in real
time which is nice or easy from an
engineering standpoint
any questions before I jump into
experiments
um so let me show you two experiments
one on Diabetes diagnosis and another
one on Dynamic pricing
um so this one is uh again this is the
same 13 Hospital example I've been
showing you but in more detail so we've
got 4 000 ish patients uh the mean
Hospital only serves about 300ish
patients who are relevant to kind of the
diabetes diagnosis test so the cohort is
relatively small the median's about 300
patients we are about 76 features uh
gotten from their demographic
information patient conditions
medications these are the features that
we saw before these are sort of hand
selected based on you know what people
considered relevant for diabetes right
and you can see that this is somewhat
High dimensional we're talking about you
know like 300 ish patients and we have
you know 75 features so that's not great
um and so we have about two arms so
whether or not we assign the treatment
uh we're gonna model a binary reward
which is that if you give them the right
treatment that's good
um and then we're going to compare it to
the Oracle which is the estimated true
model using all the data uh the kind of
the OLS banded algorithm a high
dimensional Bandit algorithm and one
multitask banded algorithm from the
literature
um and basically this is what we see
um on the x-axis is the number of
patients and so the first plot is for a
data for instance the second plot is for
a relatively data Rich instance uh and
you can see that in all cases like uh uh
the RM banded kind of hits the Oracle
much faster and it struggles more for
the data for instance that's just
because the time Horizon is kind of
pulled out over longer so during the
same amount of time we're seeing a lot
more patients accumulate in this plot
than we are in that plot right yes
I wonder how do you chose
I think cross-validation we just did
like a grid
and pick the best looking plot but
that's a question
well we're just I think individually
search each one just
you probably need some assumption on
like the population
so there's an actual population queries
so we're using actual medical data
um so we're not assuming anything we're
just throwing it at the data that we're
seeing uh the only assumption maybe is
like you know permute we don't actually
have timestamps so we don't know the
exact sequence in which patients come uh
so we take a random implementation of
the patients
great uh and so we see that there are
about uh 30 fewer errors from doing the
kind of multitask uh robust approach
than not using past Hospital information
so uh that's just an argument for saying
we should share information sharing
information can really you know help
speed up learning for whether you're a
medium-sized hospital or like a data
poor hospital
um and then we did a similar thing with
a dynamic pricing data set which I think
Han found on kaggle
um so this is a meal delivery company uh
it has about seven stores so I think
it's something like hello fresh or Blue
Apron uh they have a weekly sales of 51
different meal plants over 145 weeks but
not all of them have the full coverage
and so the mean is that we see about
6747 week plan like product observations
uh and they're about 18 features so this
is a less High dimensional if you will
there's a lot more observations fewer
features uh and the features are things
like email promotions whether it was
featured in the home page the cuisine
type the food category and so on
um and so he assumes kind of a linear
demand function uh and so there's been
work on this from like the dynamic
pricing folks like Dan and Cascade on
like Dynamic pricing with features uh so
we adapt this to kind of what uh our
algorithm might look like so we just
kind of plug in different estimators
where they use kind of OLS so you might
have like an OLS version a lasso version
this Goblin version and then you know
the robust multitask version yeah so
what are the actions here uh the action
is a continuous action now so it's the
actual price that you want to get yeah
so that's why we're just seeking our
estimator into a standard Dynamic
pricing algorithm so this isn't the
Bandit anymore
so it's more like a linear Bandit or
quadratic Bandit I guess you have demand
is like a linear function of price uh
and then you're optimizing Revenue which
is price times demand so it's kind of
quadratic interaction
yeah so here we get to see the so we see
the stores policy observed from data and
so it's not as clean as a diabetes
example but given the linear function
and the whole data set we can
extrapolate what might be an optimal
price
so we see a price path and then we
extrapolate from that
in the diabetes example we have actual
counterfactuals because then the patient
shows up next week with diabetes not
next week hopefully that'll be really
sad
so you're assuming that the demand
coefficients themselves are also
perturbations are all surprise
oh yes yes excellent so like the the
model is I believe uh so that's we sold
this from Ben and keskin so it's like uh
beta x times a plus uh B times beta so
there's like a linear transformations of
the features and then each feature is
also productive with the price right so
you get a price feature dependent
outcome but it's all linear uh and so
that's the beta that we take and then we
assume that those are response for the
patients excellent question I should
have put that in here and are there like
is this like um
you have to worry about the cost of
ecstasy or anything yes so
did you yeah do you quit sparsing this
on the cross elasticities as well yeah
so I think okay I think we have products
specific like pink syntax so we have
product
um that captures some cross elasticities
but I think we don't have press velocity
across instances because
um I guess we just assume there wouldn't
be substitution but there might be yeah
um
um cool I know I'm hearing everyone's
patience so hold around quickly uh the X
factors We have basically the number of
observations so these are the weak plan
observations uh and the y-axis we have
regret
um and so this gray line is basically
the estimated store policy of course
your other
um they're following a static policy so
we expect it to get linear regret it's
not optimized with respect to this data
um and then we see like kind of the
other banded algorithms compared to you
know what we think is the optimal policy
that are all learning right uh and so
again same kind of pattern here we see
about a six percent estimated Revenue
increase then not using cross-door
information so if we just treated each
store separately uh then we would you
know do worse which you know you kind of
might expect uh and notice that this
number is much smaller than the hospital
example I think because this is a much
less High dimensional problem so I think
this really underscores the need for
transfer learning and kind of high
dimensional problems uh because that's
really where uh we struggle to learn in
these small data settings and this
problem you know less so I can pretty
much get away with learning
independently if I needed to right
cool so just to summarize uh we're
working on transfer learning effectively
across simultaneous heterogeneous
Bandits uh we impose an assumption of
the sparse differences kind of motivated
by real data sets on how models
transport uh and then we had to design a
robust multitask estimator that
basically is able to exploit this
structure so we improve regret balance
in the context Dimension D notably it's
exponential for any kind of data for a
more High dimensional instances I think
there's a lot of exciting work kind of
in this area we've done some work on
combining short and long-term outcomes
in clinical trials or trying to learn
across many thoughts and sampling
experiments uh so there's a lot of
interesting I think exciting things to
do here was that all wrap up thank you
foreign
are just not aligned with that but I
think you can impose the same assumption
right like all arms kind of have a
shared parameter like maybe if you're in
like representation systems or something
like that you have a observable
attribute and then maybe you add some
instant specific idiosyncratic bias that
you try to learn
um I think it would be mathematically
equivalent
yeah
that's an excellent question
um so we've done this for quadratic
neural Nets with a single layer so very
specific uh because quadratic neural
that's basically you know boiled down to
regression with some rotation symmetry
uh and so if you want to add uh the
source deviation that's fine we're
trying to understand how to do this for
like realu activations it's a little
trickier because you know you have to
design a specific algorithm but I think
even there in my work because you might
want to like zoom into the linear part
of the reboot and then you know maybe
you could do something similar uh but
the answer is I don't
know
how was expiration done here
exploration for this yeah uh so we're
building off of the high dimensional
Bandit literature so basically trade off
between four sampling uh and having kind
of an uh my outfit sample estimator
we didn't do anything different
foreign
detection but it's like small
or sparse
yeah I think
I think you have a detection problem
there which we don't have right
I'm just assuming that whatever change
happens it is sparse right also every
time there is a change point I'm only
going to add as far as additive
parameter maybe I don't even need to
detect it I just take small amount of
data right
right that's really interesting I have
not thought about that
I guess if you told me when the changes
would happen I would just worry that by
the time I detected there's a change
using change my estimation I already
have collected enough data to do
estimation or at least my experience
would change Point estimation has not
been great like I usually need a large
course of before I should find with it
um
yeah that's cute yeah thanks I have not
thought about that
did you oh yeah okay I actually yeah so
the question was just like
one rather than assuming that like sort
of like the difference between the tasks
is sparse
you could model this as just saying the
difference is captured by some function
class which has like low complexity you
thought about modeling it that way at
all we did and then we got stuck on this
that makes sense I mean this was kind of
like not trivial already so no I agree I
think uh getting this like shared
parameters like a little bit tricky
because it becomes sort of like an
outlier approval problem but I think
once you nail that I can imagine that
yeah if you're willing to do any
additive low complexity model I think it
would probably generalize but I'm not
sure uh because we the way we're
removing the Corruptions is very
specific to instructions yeah for sure
uh so I think once you've fixed that it
would work but if you have any ideas all
right it says good
um other questions
thank you